Is Election Day.
It is primary election day in Arkansas.
Please, please,
please find somewhere to vote.
Go to voterview.org.
Get your polling locations.
If you're in line by 7:30,
you'll get to vote. Okay.
There are very few people that vote in primaries,
which makes your voice that much more important,
that much bigger in the election.
I've made several videos on the Supreme Court races,
especially. Vote your conscience.
Do what you think is best.
You don't have to do what I'm doing.
I don't want you to do what I'm doing
just because I'm doing it, okay?
I've got my reasons,
and you can have yours.
I just want you to vote.
We have got to move away from being a non voting state.
It matters, and it matters so much
in the primaries. Vote today.